[Music]
[Applause]
drew brees will be part of the nbc team
he was the mvp of super bowl 44 now part
of the nbc sports super bowl pre-game
show that will start on sunday that's a
long day for you drew uh are you ready
how do you prepare for something like
this
we've been
spent a lot of yesterday at sofi
and we'll spend a lot of the next two
days there as well
just going through the sets and
rehearsals and
everything that we want to talk about
and cover for uh for the fans tuning in
prior to the game and during halftime in
postgame
tougher to prepare for a super bowl
playing or as a broadcaster
i'd much rather be playing in it
uh you know
you know there's there's uh there's
certainly butterflies both ways you know
it was
uh uncharted territory the first time we
we played the super bowl
um and so you're you know you're trying
to navigate what your process is gonna
be for those two weeks you know the
first week is spent at home and then the
second week you know at the host site
and ours was in miami so it was a pretty
crazy atmosphere um but felt like we
managed it well and obviously had a
had a big had a big win against the
colts um but uh but yeah here
i mean look the weather is cooperating
this is about as beautiful as as you
could you could ever imagine down here
in southern california la for this week
um i know
the covid uh
um you know still lingers a little bit
so it's not maybe as crazy as as it
normally would be you know at a super
bowl host site but uh it certainly feels
like everybody's having a good time
though when you run into peyton manning
what's the conversation like
well we didn't have a bet
not too long ago on the purdue tennessee
uh music city bowl game
um
and and initially that was
it was all right you know what are we
gonna bet all right let's do a nice
crisp hundred dollar bill with the other
guy's signature on that you know sent in
the mail and
purdue won that game in like triple
overtime it was a crazy game probably
one of the better bowl games
that we saw
and uh i i hadn't received my hundred
bucks yet so i'm like peyton what's the
deal as i said i said now you either
send me 100 bucks or you take me duck
hunting
uh because i hear he's got a pretty good
duck hunting spot so he's like all right
deal so sounds like we're going duck
hunting instead so i'll let you know how
it goes have you ever brought up the
super bowl that you played against him
no
no
that's that's uh
that was that was a good memory for me
maybe not for him um
can you joke about it can you joke with
him about beating him in a super bowl
i don't know if we're there yet
i wouldn't
i i don't know if i would want that if i
were on the other
side um
but uh no we we've got a great
relationship and and we've we've had fun
i i i made an appearance on the uh on
the peyton and eli broadcast uh this
year we didn't we didn't talk super bowl
we talked a bunch of other stuff were
you aware that
sean payton was gonna start the second
half of the super bowl with an onside
kick
oh yeah
oh yeah we we knew
we knew that
from
the start of the week uh he had given it
a nickname so the name of the play was
ambush
rightfully named
and
he basically said it's not a matter of
if we're going to call this it's when
and so
from the very beginning he set the tone
that you know
don't get nervous don't get tight
as to whether we're going to call us we
are and it has to work when we do
because we're going to have to steal the
possession in this game if we want to
win we knew the firepower it was on the
other side of the ball with peyton
manning and if you recall they jumped
out to a 10 10 nothing lead after the
first two drives
um and then we settled it down
and brought it to
to ten to six by half time got a couple
field goals
and then here we are kicking the ball
off to them in the second half and felt
like they'll never expect it
and sure enough they did it and we got
it and
worked out well
okay but you're planning he's going to
do this
to start the second half
or at some point there's going to be an
onside kick
yeah so he we didn't know when
but he said we are going to call this in
the game like it's going to happen so so
stay ready stay ready and so we go in at
halftime and super half time it takes
forever right it's twice as long as a
normal half time maybe 40 minutes
so
you know we we we go in and literally
before we can take our pads off and
uh start getting ready for the second
half he says hey ambush is coming and so
all of a sudden it just starts spreading
through the locker room you know like
ambush is coming ambush is coming yeah
and so there was this level of
excitement uh you know to start that
second half you know we're taking we're
supposed to be taking off our pads and
eating turkey sandwiches and just
you know kind of kicking our feet up um
but all of a sudden it just it just
changed the mood a bit wait you're
eating at half time
well like i said normally you would
normally you're just in there maybe
quick snack adjustments boom you're out
the door it's like a 12 minute half time
but i mean now with the the halftime
show and just everything that's taken
place it's that's that's as much a part
of the spectacle as as the game
so you you have a lot of time and they
tell you don't get don't get too worked
up you know kick your feet up take your
pads off get a bite to eat it's going to
be a while
if you could give advice
to joe burrow or matthew stafford you
had to pick one who would you who would
you think could use
use your advice on sunday
well i'm sure it's joe burrow um
because
you know
stafford has mcvay and the rams who have
who were there a few years ago right so
at least
there's some uh experience as to what
that schedule was in the process and
just
uh maybe how to handle it from a
quarterback's perspective um
listen on the flip side i mean joe
burrows played a bunch of big games and
national championships and
um
you know but but i i'd say just
being being a young player especially
once you begin to you know feel what the
routine is of uh a regular season game a
playoff game you know the super bowl
super bowl is totally different from the
perspective of the week of preparation
that that's really i think that's really
where you just have to formulate your
plan in your process cause it is a it is
a one it is a long two weeks and it's
one of those where it's easy to get
distress acted uh there's a lot of stuff
going on i mean even as the little
things like who you're getting tickets
for the game right everybody's reaching
out to you wanting tickets and you gotta
so my advice was always and i i received
this from other people was get all the
tickets situated by monday tuesday's
media day like embrace the media day
like have fun with that because whether
you like it or not you know that's an
obligation so enjoy it opportunity to
talk about you and your team if you're
going to do a dinner with your
your teammates which is what we would do
every week during the season we would
usually do it on thursday night well
don't do it on thursday night because
where are you going to go and be able to
have a nice dinner without just uh you
know a ton of distractions so we did
that earlier in the week so monday night
in south beach we all went out as like
an offense and had the greatest dinner
ever i mean it was like a night to
remember
but it then just allowed us to kind of
put that behind us and all right here we
go you know we're gonna we're focused on
the game now what made it the greatest
greatest dinner
well because coach payton was paying for
it
because coach payne gave me his credit
card and said you all have a good time
because we had been bugging them all all
year because you know i was i was paying
for a lot of them and then some of the
veteran guys
and um
and and so we had been bugging sean like
sean when are you going to buy a dinner
for for the old line you know
and he's like oh it's coming he's going
to finally make this super bowl like
sean this is it like you have to buy
this one because you you missed all the
others and he's like all right here's my
credit card he literally gave me his
credit card i'm like this is dangerous
coach we're going to south beach you
know that right
so we go to uh i think we go to joe's uh
and
we get we get so many of those like snow
crab claws you know like like yeah which
are like 90 bucks a pop right i mean you
had like platters
of these things spread you know spread
out what was the tab how much did it
come to drew
it was it was it was probably 25 25
grand
[Laughter]
it was it was easy
but here's what happened you can ask
sean about this so
i i felt guilty i felt guilty about it
so i i ended up splitting the tab with
him
i pulled my credit card out i'm like all
right just split it between these two
you know
um
but yeah we we crushed it it was fun
he's uh drew brees he's uh joining us on
behalf of nbc uh their pre-game show and
also uh points bet the official sports
betting partner of nbc sports how aware
were you of the point spread when you
played in games
you know what
never
never really but
but that super bowl it's funny because
sean
sean was looking for
every way
to
you know try to give us confidence you
know going into that game you know
that's that season for the colts was an
unbelievable season i mean they were
really like an undefeated team
um
they were 14 and two but they had really
lost their last two games on purpose
if you recall they they would play their
starters for the first half and then sit
them for the last two years or the last
two games because you remember what
happened
in some of the previous years where you
know i kind of they felt that pressure
of like the undefeated seasons in 2004
and five and other so so so they were
really like an undefeated team
when we played them and so there was
this feeling like man these guys are
unbeatable and or at least that's i
think what what the media and everybody
wanted to
to try to communicate and so
i think for us it was like listen sean's
like i think i think we're the better
team and and here's and here's and
here's why and here's what
america thinks too i think the point
spread early in the week was maybe like
10 points and then crept down to nine
and eight and seven and by game time was
like five and a half or something like
that
um but bottom line it was it was it was
trickling down in our favor and i think
he wanted to show that
you know what it's not just the guys in
this room that believe this like you
have the power of the who dat nation you
have the power of this the the country
too feeling like you know what there's
something special with you guys
you guys can do this
what bothers you more does it bother you
that the bengals are who day and the
saints were who dat
let's clear this up you got a problem
with the bengals
no no i i like i like our champ better
than theirs okay
you know who that who that who that city
gonna beat them saints um you know
there's obviously a little like cajun
you know southeast louisiana
uh kind of slang with that right and and
what helped me out is who de jude who
day
and it's not
who they going to beat them bengals or
how do they how exactly do they say it
and then it's nobody right
you like that
uh yeah listen i i love i love when you
have chants and stuff that the the fans
can do in the stadium that gets it riled
up like we we uh tareko and i broadcast
the the wild card game at cincinnati uh
when they played the raiders and that
was my first time hearing it in the
stadium and i was like i love it i love
it that's that's similar to what we do
in the superdome to get everybody
rocking before the game
so i love that just like you're in
kansas city and the home of the chiefs
right like just something stuff
hey stuff that brings the fans together
i love it yeah uh points bet the
official sports betting partner of nbc
sports the only sports book to offer
live in game same game parlay options
for the big game available in 10 states
recently launched in new york and
pennsylvania which one of brady's
records
bothers you the most that he took from
you
oh man
i'm um
let's see did he he took the he took the
completions record that's all right he
can have that
um
30 yards record right he he had he had
the touchdowns already he
he's lucky i got hurt for
for uh nine games aaron donald you know
messed up this thumb was out for five
and then one of his teammates it was
actually uh william goldston
he sagged me he's the one who who
fractured all those ribs to start and
then and then one of those d lyman from
the niners fractured the other three
um
the next week
so he
his teammate helped him out honestly uh
or else i i would have
i might i might have had the touchdown
record
um you think brady do you think brady's
done he said never say never
oh he left the door open obviously
look there is a um
it'll always live with us all right
it'll always live with us um
i mean look
there's
if you if you told me right now like one
of these teams of some having a
quarterback they're like hey we need a
quarterback play we come and play i'd
play
i'd play in a second
um
just you just you're wired that way man
you're wired yeah but sean reached out
to you this season how close were you to
coming back and playing for the city i
was very close i was very close i was
very close to coming back complaint for
that one game
so there were some there were some other
factors in other circumstances but um
yeah i mean i think it always it always
lives inside you uh that fire and
and i think
you're just you're just wired a certain
way and i think you can just you can
flip the switch
you can flip the switch so
uh you find other ways i think that's
what's hard about retirement is you have
to find other ways to channel that
competitive drive and that fire
um and i wouldn't say that's been easy
you know but it's
it's just it's the way we're wired and
that's what we have to find
thanks again for uh joining us this
season have fun on sunday and don't
think about the number of people
watching you
it's only it's only like you know it's
like only like half of it only like half
a billion
it's not a whole billion like it's just
a half a billion
and you know what nobody's gonna be on
twitter nobody's gonna be judging you
don't worry about it just have fun
that's exactly what i'm gonna do have
fun talk ball
make make make fun make fun of uh
make fun of what i see no it'll be fun
uh thanks again great to see you and uh
thanks again for joining us
you too dan thanks that's drew brees a
former saints quarterback super bowl 44
mvp in the uh pregame festivities the
starting uh says the pregame show at one
eastern on sunday nbc in pecan